three
ah
yeah
hey what if i always held the
microphone like this like it's a handheld
it would be weird yeah no one
can see it but imagine being weird
hey by the way this is our
second hey by the way is your
second one episode back where we are
hearing the theme song do you want
to credit who made the theme song
lie friend from before we met in
summer
school leading into new orleans for saw
i didn't know them scoring lap kissed
my name is paul f tompkins i'm
scott ocher duty um his name is
mike mullarkey he's an extremely talented musician
he has perfect pitch he's got so
many things going on and habs love
with this i meant offering him um
and he's just extremely talented and he
did the same
song fur with special guest as well
as raised by tv and i'm saying
this i also wanna say this is
our second episode back that we've known
the title of the show wow well
they don't we don't know where that
is yet to be proven right we
don't know if this if freedom is
the title yet we definitely yeah but
we've been listening as each episode comes
out paul and i have been and
we
haven't gotten to one where we have
no i know we have end of
the tenth episode that isn't episode eight
we actually say is where we kind
of relent and say it's me but
i just listened to it yeah ok
i'm a bit didn't finish it i
mean imagine a minute of it have
you ever been at a wedding good
good yes yes good how dare you
have you ever been
in a wedding and someone gives a
speech you know like they're in love
with oh god i was a room
on the fall that was like that
where it was the i don't want
to get on a specific but he
was in the fall interesting um but
it was the computer give me shit
lately all within it in the fall
of twenty seventeen jus
for the record i enhanced i didn't
really know anyone at this wedding so
i don't so i feel like it's
not really like that bad disease um
the the best man i guys spoke
and then he talked about the bribes
oh it's always the best yes lovingly
yeah right and protectively unlike we read
so glad
really i'm just glad she finally found
someone who's going to treat her the
way she deserves everyone is looking around
going like he loves her yeah like
her life sorry
i love my drop can i say
something loves her i recently broke time
lord your love strap that goes right
you know i recently built by mailman
in depth and his voice has one
of those puffs out like i did
you take your million and depth devastating
ah cinch style
nah just the other day not a
chili dog when he came up delivering
my shit wrong up your butt and
i decided he was talking about how
he was gonna come back with something
else and yeah we'd come over so
because these things are cash something like
i'll come back here in tampa i
can five minutes with some other and
then i was like
oh wow he talks like that like
that was one of those things like
like his work upon review from ours
but it's one of those things you
hear it in cartoons or later some
people have were kind of into it
yeah charming to see a person and
what did he come back with some
cougar stuff
you've finally got your loot crate a
guy may quip to expression mummy thirty
five minutes i like her closer dip
shit he had
i was actually ten minutes what he's
ten minutes and he was delivering some
packages news come back with the regular
paper mail so he had a plan
peeper i don't know i'm going to
bring only half your stuff and then
walk for admitting he had explained it
but i did have fun realizing i
could do the voice my my arms
are all full of your mail
i have to give me this ma'am
now with a more bilingual
um i don't think i've ever gotten
into any sort of conversation with my
male i think i've met most of
my mailman um and i think i
tipped them at the holidays sure we
do that oh how nice of you
to change something can achieve something yeah
we used to in our old place
we used to have the same
male gps whatever for the longest time
longest huh oh it's not good huh
and then all of a sudden we
would get a person when we suddenly
yasuo one editor oh geez oh no
there's a little day
the way your teeth is a little
did a little dance like eighteen would
do a little dance make love get
down get down tonight so this person
has gone oh who did whatnot so
then it started to be just people
that were there for a few months
and then it would constantly wrote
update and we would we ever would
rotate the the same people came back
and they never came back so it
would just be it would just be
new people every two months
and that has transferred to our new
home where we've been for the last
few years is that we don't have
we it started the same way where
we'd have the the regular guy you
know every single time and then it
would be every few months it would
be a different person oh what government
job would you most enjoy
probably that president of the united states
i think like she's really polished
go to reach for the star i
love to open my finances up for
everyone to see wedding wedding clerk like
you know there's lots of like i
think yeah the post office worker like
that woman who wouldn't marry gay people
but you could do that you could
be like i say no oh kim
davis oh david you know what i
wish why should jim davis from oh
yeah that's right she hey
eats everything yeah she eats she wouldn't
i tuesday wednesday thursday and friday and
gay people
i love lasagna my booze gay people
brought her lasagna she could bridge the
device and your litterbox um she not
she i think the station buildings are
to go from it oh i want
a dehumanizing call you see
government buildings are so depressing and i
say they don't they purposely don't put
any money towards them like males die
for jobs yeah like it's just sad
like post offices like usually are really
shitty looking well like get this queer
eye up in here in fix this
like how queer eye open fire station
was so awesome i was because nobody's
fixed oh yeah the first was right
isn't it because a lot of the
government
and buildings were built in the sixties
or seventies and that was a particularly
drab time for architecture well yeah but
i mean eternally like it's just like
they didn't internally they're very utilitarian and
and and depressing it's true and they
could be nice if they're going to
be if you know that nice you're
my nice
if you note that these agencies are
going to be around for decades and
decades and decades why not but you
have people in the seventies like yeah
i i don't know if you feel
the way i feel that seventy architectures
just are you telling me i love
you i think elena but out of
hideous stuff but don't do you
i think that they were like people
are gonna love this five ten fifteen
twenty five eighty years right yeah i
think it was just very much like
let's get this up and get it
done we're gonna make it a jitter
done yeah we're gonna get her done
right we're gonna make this just a
bach because the stuff of mormon like
like the stuff downtown or the or
the post office that's sorted down over
there like they're beautiful bills
readings like well yeah yeah that was
the archer or nothing which has been
columns with the columns
awesome dems don't
we were talking off air about the
cosby mysteries if it was that we
do all the time was that his
guess raised cause of death murder
cause i don't remember who it was
breda did they do it in esa
now you're doing yes okay maybe they
didn't know adam sandler did the cosby
mysteries and he would ask people things
like where are we on the night
of the plaza
it's like it's funny because the embosser
was funny oh he was in full
blackface blackface in comedy hung in there
for a long time can i throw
out this thought tuition i recently watched
the new adam sandler not new anymore
to listeners ah movie on netflix called
the week of i laughed a ton
did you really i heard that once
about i thought it was i met
the actress who played his wife in
bentonville arkansas
and shuttled to the oh restrict life
i was like rachel draft the actress
who played yeah you know yeah his
wife was great she was a cast
member of saturday vi um yeah the
whole cast was really good um anyways
i thought was very funny smile directed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah robert smuggle
for the people not rodeo events too
yeah so
it's good alright i'll check it out
maybe it's not maybe it's cleaning up
its nose yeah you be the judge
what's the hold on a second i
got a mailman story oh here we
go the longest mailman the wrong ismail
manager oh yeah was this guy in
our old neighborhood in those fields and
he was an how long one shouldn't
match
man what how long was he we
lived there for five years and i
would save for know how long was
he his body my friend he was
like so forehands high
okay thank you for putting it into
her forehand he was horse horse okay
you're describing like miniatures yeah it was
a little one of those little ponies
okay but do you think it's probably
best pill grown yeah and he had
a hat on on his hind legs
though yeah oh yeah okay got it
okay yeah sure he was this ancient
ancient age
ant man and he spoke very little
english um which made it difficult when
you were trying to say to him
hey
the fuck where is my mail hey
where's my mail like because people would
be walking across history poser that's the
first sentence he would learn we would
be giving him our mail to each
other in the neighbourhood like chicago came
here like a block yeah already everyone
meets a feisty actually like really good
this we really get to know our
neighbors it's like bipolar we were constantly
getting like
like he would just leave stuff out
and would get opened and stolen and
things like that so you try to
tell him don't okay don't look this
year much oh and he would because
we would travel a lot he would
ignore the old male god and so
we we come home and like there'd
be like a pile of shit on
our front door like like lundell i'm
average over that
hold me you never done a hold
mail i say so great god and
you owe us a feeling of power
i don't deliver this yeah it's actually
the opposite should be true of like
i'm gonna make you deliver this but
we got in a big argument one
time as best as we could you
i wish that was a wrong time
we never stop we're also circus but
you guys are into you gotta deal
with a mailman yes because i knew
that he had done something wrong and
he was denying that he had done
this and then i it was heartbreaking
because just wanting to paddle his bottom
i wanted to take me teach a
little lesson and some of the
that path i wasn't gonna like the
medium i was just gonna like give
him a few swats are you impaired
yet stood what i owe that i
was upset yeah um what the look
on his face when he realized i
saw the realization come over his face
that he realized he was wrong and
it was fucking heartbreaking oh because then
all of us because this guy had
been kind of my enemy you know
what amy yeah
now that all of a sudden he
was like oh this poor old man
you know like he wasn't being an
asshole on purpose he like realised oh
i yeah my row fully he had
been an asshole on purpose many times
yeah i'm not wrong oh no i'm
wrong i'm not wrong i'm not saying
hey i'm wrong and i'm very sad
and relatable
but yeah you would be like me
isn't that a lesson for us off
we just dropped our defend that for
me okay
the lesson i got out of those
never get old so janie and i
have a packed what we have discussed
this two years from now really yep
two years ago to see why we
never two years ago it's two years
from now huh
today your mind bill and ted excellent
that just three coming soon we it's
true it's going to be in that
we asher what do you wanna be
like bill's brother i want to be
like the box to go in that
day tim time traveling you want to
be when you go in your box
on the phone booth i want be
fumble i won't be vom
i'd be anything that movie if you
could be in any sql to any
movie like they're like any movie is
gonna make a sequel they announce it
what movie would that be would you
just like killer tune
i guess what i mean is a
sql that doesn't exist right but i
want to be in the sql back
to the future to i would that
one exist it's called back to the
future three
the sequel to back to the future
two it must decide today is i
thought it was just another movie called
back to the future and they're like
oh well the first two are taken
we're gonna so it's it's like finding
an email address
yes the future three oh well we're
three at the edge they tried to
that was already gone there was already
over three
i would be in big too big
too i love big big dude but
he would not be good that's thing
well but no but okay so let's
say it's amazing and now they announce
it in tom hanks is like i'm
going back to the well yeah and
i'd be like give me in that
way what and who would you want
to be would you want a big
the big the jeweler bomb i guess
i will be like their daughter from
when they had sack what if okay
so what ooh wait are you saying
that saw elizabeth perkins gets knocked up
by tom yeah when he's fourteen ah
but then he and she's got big
disease too because because he was in
the middle of a magic
curse when he did it so his
sperm is all like a big baby
has it that's what i'm saying yes
the baby comes out big baby when
a baby is born and adult and
and his tears up her vaginas dead
and she's like she of course i
work at a factory the guy heard
the last words or i work at
a toy factory do you think though
it could be a good sql
if it's tom hanks has aged he's
aged into where he is new to
the adulting when he finds the he
finds this adult daughter now
time i'm the daughter finds results are
does not come back to the original
oh no the original humanities overwhelming kid
and that the that the machine was
based on and she find family originals
older humans this concept the wait how
could it ever make sense they'd have
to be like close to the same
age
he have to be only fourteen years
older than her well yeah he'd have
to be only fourteen years old but
that's that lines up with where you're
at so you're saying i'm almost seventy
nine years old how old is tom
no i don't he's eighty one years
old
it it could be you can adjust
how
tom hanks is sixty one series oh
just tanks say it's for it so
he's like you gotta be forty seven
sixty one okay you start
we have double siri confirmation you can
adjust you can adjust the the age
of the people yeah you can age
oh no no no i'm saying i'm
a little older he's younger yeah because
you need the middle so so he
comes and tracks you down yeah and
you have big disease where you're you're
staying the same age the whole time
no i'm because you're born big i'm
normal you're born being normal i'm normal
wanna do it like for real okay
i'm normal but then i get the
chance
to to be as old as him
as old as him and then he
tries to date me like it's back
to the future ah and then and
he does and then i have a
baby with him uh-huh and he's just
like raw dog and everyone that
huh
what if it's tom hanks and he
now he's the adult but he wants
to be small again so the sequel
the biggest small right he was just
like oh my god i'm too old
now he wants to be an amazing
kid actor we have to get amazing
guy who's older than the kid was
in the in the original so he
wants to go back to an age
we
haven't twenty eight yeah and so he's
like i wish i wish i could
redo my twenties because i was so
yeah i can still rent a car
because i'm older than twenty five well
because he was like i was like
i was very important i can buy
a r fifteen i was strand myself
he was holding onto what he experienced
when he got to be made big
so when he
turned twenty eight he was like you'd
like something like that i was like
i had this great job at the
toys played i was and i danced
around with an old man i now
know i am the old man now
working at barnes noble against my will
or something yeah so he wants to
go back to this he wants to
go back and then you see you
use like cut scenes deleted scenes from
big four
for when he goes back yeah and
from any movie like any deleted scene
from any of his movies sleepless in
seattle
punchline i wanna do this movie where
the last surviving parts and it's making
people work there against their will so
they can hang all it's gotta be
set in the future because he's yeah
because he's older yeah because he's the
age tom hanks is next which would
be saying what twenty years in future
he's oh so huh
oh he is enslaved person noble the
like barnes and noble the last day
yeah that's yeah instituted slavery
yes i like this this is a
good sequence like this is really rich
what would you be in
i don't know how let me think
ok so my i don't know like
ah although you know i was gonna
say pee wees big adventure but um
he's already it wouldn't sequel that would
just be another adventure whatever and he's
already kind of done it it's from
a small adventure ah um eight and
a half maybe
eight and a half with that nine
oh no that's already been done um
what nine is was the musical version
of eight and a half huh editing
ah um citizen kane too yeah revenge
a rose bud rose bans yeah gotta
get that set out there no well
maybe something like break-in or something like
that flash i remember citizen kane being
the most boring movie i watched n
satchel it's so good oh they played
it in school and i was like
theirs
luck and work
it's great you know my brother that
actually i heard being like those hell
i was probably writing notes the intec
oh it's incredible my brother does not
see the point of black and white
movies and he's my brother's not dumb
right right you would think that stabled
like that would come from a dumpers
yeah he's a smart person he's like
i just don't understand why why
what is the point of that now
that we have color considering that was
the thing we were forced to do
no yeah kinda considering like when was
the first color movie because the first
one i can think of is like
you know wizard of oz that eighteen
thirty whatever sort of us it wasn't
the first no it wasn't the first
thing i wonder when i can go
cool as a way to reveal color
of just like well first coding movie
it's gonna happen yeah but i guess
my point is is like there were
black and white movie i mean there
still are but i mean there were
commonly black and white movies through the
sixty yes thirty years after color was
still exist and there's just that much
cheaper i think it's a certain aesthetic
here's a reference lauren might not get
if we go back i like this
feature side note the first film shot
color was cupid angling made eight nineteen
eighteen the wizard of oz and gone
with the wind were made in technicolor
in nineteen thirty nine and processed that
have been around for quite some time
by then there were hand-coloured segments in
movies dating back to nineteen o two
yeah like what's his name linda turner
okay tell me your story but you
know like hand coloring each each frame
wow
like pencils and stuff when we were
ah i would say this this was
the eighties into the nineties while it
was like hollywood into the nineties black
and white headshots like everyone else yeah
shots i did i had like did
you have like i'm gonna chuck i'm
no i didn't but i got them
when i got mine for the first
time color was pretty
the new yeah well yeah doesn't why
because color had shots ah were you
could have made them think was more
but it was weird it was a
weird it was more expensive like if
you if you were like i remember
when color headshots were introduced it was
like are people really gonna go for
color shots like they want to know
what color my hair and eyes make
so much more sense yeah
for so long now i have for
so long the last time you had
to have black and white headshots last
headshots i ever took in ninety seven
i think were black-and-white yeah yeah it
was weird wow it was very weird
is strange yeah it was kooky it
was nice it was creepy and it's
completely hidden bouquet and you're lucky it
was altogether
ooh
no and if as i write a
song if the rules are that ix
altogether oogie huh
so i wish there was a third
okie word but he's kooky spooky yeah
it must have been like trying to
save the actors money right because there's
no other explanation for i think it
was more expensive but but i think
it was trying to gouge the donors
don't you it was more expensive to
do black and white why wouldn't it
lasting director wanna have it have a
color
because they're not paying for the headshots
but don't they want to but don't
they want to know what why wouldn't
they can direct you would have to
like my movie's gonna be in color
and it's like yeah casting it based
on how people look doesn't want any
chance there's whole thing doesn't make any
sense i feel like we're living in
a alternate reality where like that can't
be the path all the money fold
that's a good point shot
good point paul do you have do
you have a movie you'd like to
be in the movies i'm thinking of
that i love they wouldn't have schools
like wow because we can beat it
out like a movie like huh
this movie that ah whenever i bring
up no one has ever seen topsy
turvy topsy turvy yes i'm like i
have it at home but i haven't
watched it yet see there we go
it's a great movie yes it's about
good-bye bought it on your recommendation but
it's a wonderful food on your shelf
forever yes i've watched it it's a
wonderful film but it's like it's a
contained story about what historical people it's
about
gilbert and sullivan and the creation of
the mikado okay so then what else
do they create pirates of penzance fucking
pretentious today just mikado it's about gilbert
sullivan the trial although one of my
favorite film you sound like men already
open a little studio sixty would you
want if you could just be in
some movie would that be the movie
you would pay
pick if it's like you we should
just be good to be in there
and yeah that that movie learns arabia
if i could have been in jaws
if i could write pay to the
editor of lawrence and i know andy
coats who when when they were restoring
lawrence of arabia it was like the
the fiftieth anniversary i mean it's when
i first moved to town because i
remember they've showed it at the sit
around feeling we saw it once at
the center
around the dome together nick me because
i've seen it like three times they're
at the center yeah so i feel
like it must have gone with you
i remember one time going with my
friend bryan whalen and i had never
seen it on a big screen before
and we sat in the very front
row this in ramadan which is a
massive theater here in los angeles and
sit in the front row the screen
is gigantic and you felt like you
were in the movie
it was yeah that's sad it was
a lot of fun so you wouldn't
pick that because you already felt like
you're in it yeah exactly so i
did that but the tie at the
time that they were restoring that movie
um because they were you know they
were there were finding different bits and
pieces and restoring like literally restoring it
when they found
her and v codes like she'd still
worked but she was right she did
out of sites your forever she worked
forever yeah she was wearing a masters
of the universe ah the movie star
movie yeah the skeletal movie and it's
like hey could you come and work
on the restaurant store here greatest achievement
i hate to take time away from
you working on masters of the universe
wow
ah i think i'd already
i ruined dirty and sister act i've
never seen that either it's a fun
movie ah um i mean back to
the future yeah yeah the thing is
you took mine right off the topic
would you want him back to the
future i love bags i would love
to be in a movie where i
got to be like an a like
a period piece like that like where
it's like fifties
yeah that'd be so fun i wonder
if that's a ah a slight generational
thing because we're just a few years
apart but i don't have the same
love for but even though i loved
it i saw it it didn't it
didn't stick with me as one of
those things from when i was younger
well you i carry your heart i
was fifteen going on sixteen and i
was twenty eight
no i think you were you you
were probably like brad just about to
graduate high school or just yeah probably
yeah high school eighty five yeah it
was a junior in high school or
junior in high school when i was
a sophomore in high school or i
was about to be a sophomore in
high school you are about to be
a senior in high school because this
is the summer of eighty five i
wasn't born july of eighty first feels
sixty three
my parents were thinking about having a
baby vera thinking about fucking yeah the
oldest no no i mean i'm the
youngest you it's you and your brother
do you have other siblings have you
backtrack to like the date that your
parents fucked oh wait they weren't thing
about fucking than they were pregnant
um they maybe they think about fucking
like everything when you're pregnant you think
about it a lot yeah cool noises
happen because fucking everyone always talks about
their birthday but do you think the
day that you were contained i was
born september six so i always kind
of assumed it was new year's eve
situation yeah me too because i'm a
september as well yeah i'm i'm july
so i feel like things
getting fucked around thanksgiving of social ny
like right after thanksgiving dinner yeah and
they're just like i asked the brady
passed the baby gravy oh no oh
we need to go to a break
p the b g will be right
one more minute no no you gotta
go bye
welcome back we come back well we
can't we can't keep any time you
say welcome back what do i say
it a different way yeah single combat
something that gets me into the white
shadow theme well how did that go
how did that go that's a good
quote why did i turn this around
on me wait it's it's a good
theme
boom boom wait i'm i'm just doing
fat albert
what is the white shadow theme chef
chef google googled chef google check gotta
hear that white shadow theme yeah i
was kinda right
damn is it my post dean
i had to ban been an ambition
good huh but i'm bad i'm bad
enough bad huh
oh banner fine i'm fine
wow man i'm fucking bags is really
good you know what i bought we
turned them you could like play this
at a wedding
oh really as your bride walked down
the dance scott don't be sacramento
scott yoy national anthem at that moment
i heard the wonder woman theme can
you imagine i heard the wonder woman
the other day and i was like
well this is so good i gotta
buy it let's hear it it's on
itunes oh gosh yeah google chef so
i went to dubai i don't know
who invited on i tunes it's so
good it's such a banger was it
ninety nine cents or was it fifty
nine cents i believe is a dollar
twenty nine w
they're like if you are if you
want this you're going to pay whatever
for it so we're just seeing you
know yeah it's not like you're gonna
be sitting there going like oh gosh
i don't know whether i can afford
an extra thirty cents for this impulse
buy of the wonder woman loughran are
you familiar with the wonder woman from
the back when there yeah um did
you ever see it no i didn't
only watch that type of show but
um do we
have it by the way women empowerment
thinks
uh
bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
bum bum bum
now i think the version that i
bought did not have as many car
crashes out you listen to it over
and over again
we have the dialogue nor the electric
eating new zealand
oh that's right wonder woman every episode
opener they're electrocuting criminals by torturing them
and then waterboarding moments i believe you
i believe yeah they have no way
to know do you know how she
turned into wonder woman on the tv
show she found the toilet yeah you're
not far off and it may just
as much since she
spun around in a circle oh i
didn't know that but i thought she
thought you were saying like how she
became like how like oh no she
was virgin went all the toilet yeah
she's born wonder woman but then how
does she she felt her to watch
her spin cycle machine magically turning into
diana prince because she's born wonder woman
so it's a wonder woman
is the magical listen she's born wonder
woman she's magically turning into diana prince
she spends around the circle so when
she becomes this dynamite lady winching mako
she's not turning into wonder woman she's
reverting back to her natural state i
don't know i live
think about it i really enjoyed me
this explaining wonder
maybe right here's this is the real
version she's a lady she's born wonder
woman but she's also going to pretend
to be diana prince she turns around
in a circle her clothes become the
clothes everyone's looking at like what wait
okay nobody's looking at it because then
the secret self so she doesn't private
she spent around around she's a new
lady she's the busty
ian bucks on she's gone through all
the right places she's walking around like
you don't give a damn everyone looks
at her and says what the fuck
i got off fuck this lady
now
ah please someone isolate them and turn
your somewhat isolated three and launched into
space ah oh man if you could
go to space would you i wouldn't
i i don't think i like if
it was it was like you want
a golden ticket and it's like hey
come up to space today if they
say
and daily weight guy you can go
to the moon it's one hundred percent
safe we've done it a million times
it's as safe as flying in a
plane you will return to earth it
would take so long wouldn't i would
i would maybe do it but only
if like i was like suicidal
right but it's one hundred percent fave
all of our suicide i assumed these
people were like yeah exactly
i would absolutely go to space i
wonder it from space yes i wouldn't
do a thing where it's like you
can go to mars and it takes
you know ten years you'll never see
earth how long does it take to
go to the moon i mean people
have done it and don't know how
long i mean but then again i've
seen buzz aldrin he was always just
old so maybe he came back old
do you think he lived up
there for donkey you might have had
a second home there three days gets
the mood i got that time three
days three days you would take us
six day trip because you just gonna
get up look at things and go
back row not gonna like we have
a hotel would you step foot on
the moon you'd have to wear the
suit and all that fuck yeah i'd
be so scared i don't think i
would
do it i think the trip would
be so hard it's like i can
barely get it up to go to
catalina you can barely get it up
isolate that i got some of the
space though
yeah i didn't like that
chevron do you think
that's not a bad record
catalina sucks and the moon is coo
no but hell what i'm trying to
say is like the trip to catalina
where you got to go on the
the ship that is i hate the
wavy idea bar oh i didn't know
about that i want to do it
now it's like ah you lunch hour
but i like the bar like boat
rides i love the rides and i
don't get motion sickness
okay so y'all know i don't i
do jamie and i went to iceland
we went on a trip to iceland
and we went on a whale watching
boat which should go to iceland like
soon yeah okay should i wanna go
to iceland is your name
yeah
wow just with you yeah just the
two yes yes yes looking wales in
the face i think you guys would
have a fun time just we probably
should be fine we've so we one
of those whale watching boat which bile
cut to the chase we didn't see
a single whale ah it was freezing
cold
freezing cold to the point where and
it was summer there but they will
rent you these outfits these fucking like
coveralls to wear because when you're on
the deck of the boat the wind
is so bitter it it whips through
you is like doha with it on
land not hot okay not hot this
was there somewhere and it was still
like it was not hot by sea
how had we went we were sky
how hot was it under the earth
how hot and molten cores inside your
heart ties your works to the way
i was never arrive my heart stopped
with whale hate ah it was when
thou saw a whale would you have
murdered it yeah sure you have just
part of the trip just to establish
dominance right of course i would've said
although they they do
have um they still do serve whale
in some places they have that's right
yeah and they have signs in the
windows of restaurants that don't serve well
in case you're concerning the highway like
a we're not doing that whale sade
archaic thing where there's like say there's
a big movement to not do it
anymore there is because
think anyways well because there's there's yes
now it's like no one needs that
i mean wills we kill any so
many things is it whales are almost
extinct is that what it is like
there no they're so big that they're
scary like i did i bet there
there's only room for like three of
them yeah because you kill one you
feed every restaurant in town
right there killing these whales by the
millions i don't i think it's because
of the certain type of whale i
think it probably is an extinction issue
not that the whales are are in
danger these whales might not be in
danger of extinction but it's just because
it's it used to be purely necessity
it was the only thing people could
do
there and now it's not right you
know but there are certain things that
we kill any that we that we're
fine with get a whale or a
dolphin it's like no we take trips
out on boats to look at them
we can't kill them yes but people
i mean it's the same thing with
like safari people who kill animals that
are like that right elephant
yeah i mean you when you when
you yeah that and that's even worse
is just a trade it's just virtual
vs yes but is it does get
into the thing of when you zoom
out to the macro like do we
need to be killing any we don't
need to be killing any animals at
all no no no but i think
with with the whales it is in
danger of it isn't an issue of
endangerment and being an then
being overfished if that's a term i
think it is yeah but that it's
it's it's such a um it's such
a huge waste of a life because
there are these gigantic creatures and it's
city isn't doing a great value because
it's like if you're gonna kill anything
killed the biggest thing and then you
get so much meat out of it
but they only eat
the eyes oh that's good
throw the rest away they shove it
back in the sea shiver back in
the sea
oh so anyway i'm sure we're on
this boat the whale watching boat and
the the weather was crazy the wind
was so high that the boat was
crew just it was nuts it was
just going straight up and cannot stand
that if people were off people were
throwing up left and right that's like
those plane rides you hear where it's
like sudden drops in altitude and everyone's
like yeah everywhere die
even that i don't know if that
would make me throw up the move
made me freak out for sure but
on a boat i just offering gao
what what do you think it is
about you playing you insane
i think i have a great centre
of it's i don't know no it's
purely just genetics right i think it's
just luck of the draw yeah like
like and that's how they find astronauts
because they put him through that centrifuge
and oh god i right well let's
see if this is one of the
humans that doesn't throw up from the
base who's doing the salience
bailey and test us this is one
of the humans but you know what
i mean like i want to know
what i wouldn't be able to do
it but they say that i mean
there are certainly ways to detonate um
by trying to make sure your eyes
are always following what your inner ears
right where a copper bracelet yeah wear
a condom oh god on this show
marie ca
condo before chinese marie calendar ninety day
fiance before the ninety days one of
my favorite shows what did you say
okay so let's show called ninety day
fiance well local have people there in
relationship with from another country and they
commonly get a k one visa which
gives you ninety days to get married
stay at telling figure out if they're
going to and then there's now i
spin off called before
or the ninety days and it's people
who aren't yet business call it ninety
three days because it's more than that
is when moshi got you but this
guy goes to like visit his girlfriend
in some country camping where it is
but like it involved him taking like
a plane and a boat and whatever
you know is playing the small planning
but but he's like really paranoid
about everything that he was going to
encounter that he brought this like giant
trunk with like every thing you could
possibly need any medication or like bam
jenny emerging that you hepa had condoms
because he was might have to fuck
something know isn't crazy to stay chicco
in because he was going to have
to walk
walk through water at some point and
it's to keep bugs out of your
p ho like it's awesome like he
was really overly thinking like it's like
yeah happen really and you're sure it
wasn't just like the camera crew cut
a shot of the condoms he's like
oh this is for bugs in the
p oh no he was really seriously
put two on when they got to
a point
and then he also like his mom
gave him some of her hair as
like when he was leaving and it
was from her hairbrush like she's like
pulled it out until this is for
you and he's at least clone me
she was like thank you so much
they like so strange why it wasn't
such a good show and it's so
so this guy's just insane yeah he's
ridiculous goes from an same like he
it's in a fight with the girl
and like he like runs away and
then she gets held at machete point
by whom by some random renegade instant
camera you're burying the lede here this
is the most exciting part of the
show bad for laughing at the guy
for the kind of zoe but he's
no he abandoned her and so like
he he he's an asshole
the mandate whatever it's right it's great
it's great with santee lc if anyone's
interested where did they go to a
neutral third country where the machetes happened
or was that was in her kind
of hurricane they were in a bad
area and she was trying to tell
him that and so they got into
a fight and he was like wow
it's like oh condoms huh yeah nothing's
getting up here
yeah
that's a good god yeah tarsal scott
i'm not as bad as cool op
cool up gets really both sick especially
but i'll get both sick we've been
on a couple of boats here and
there where it's just like i gotta
get off this fucking true that's how
i feel every much a second i'm
on about can you be in lauren
can you be in a car of
someone else's driving i can
but not in the back seat and
if i am in the backseat i
can't really like look at my phone
at all or like do any oh
wow i will immediately feel really sick
some people all they can do is
look in the phone because otherwise they'll
get sick oh yeah no after country
and to kind of stairs middle and
the window why does it make any
sense because the reason you get sick
is because your your vision is not
lining up with
what your inner ear is doing so
if you're looking at if you're reading
or looking at the phone your inner
ear senses you're moving but your eyes
are sensing standing still what about people
with robot arms i forgot sorry that
i can't say look up centre window
like the the driver window if you
look out the driver window then you
can see where you're going like the
driver never gets car sick because
does he or she is actually affect
or they are actually affecting the movements
of the car the alfa yeah exactly
i'm car cars my dog i control
every move it makes so i feel
every time i get in although the
driver i have gotten carsick driving before
really
your swipe you know
you know we don't want like that
crazy taxi you know what it was
it was i realised this when i
did more research on aids that i
was in a windy road and i
was listening to the music really loud
and it was it must have been
affecting my my inner ear so i
just turned off the music and rolled
down the window and then you feel
better because you're actually like oh music
effects your inner ear we were driving
windy road we went to a wedding
in mendoza xeno and and was this
the one where the groom the best
man stood up and was in love
with the bride no have you so
you've all witnessed that two eyewitnesses was
that on this episode i don't know
did we talk about jonas episode don't
know chevron chevron must have been last
episode your show
shaking your head like you don't know
and by the way shaking your head
we've asked two different questions and i
don't know which you're shaking
he just leaned into the microphone should
gossip now that was on the last
episode right um we were driving this
windy road and we had this i
wish i could have found the song
we were listening to whatever radio station
was coming in because it was weird
reception and it was fucking perfect it
was this weird
instrumental song and it made you feel
like you were in a movie like
the soundtrack to this you know part
of the movie were like dramatic like
dorm room yeah it was kind of
down learn yeah did that's exactly what
it was thanks i just shazam do
so zile or about gary gauley stay
who schatz aren't shock know he was
this yeah this is my jacket britain
golly here's mine shocked i'm a big
guy or are on track for pay
packages for you or you have to
bring them back my arm just too
big and we get packages we can't
go yeah tightly to but that's actually
my jacket version when you see commercials
for the oh yeah it was the
ice college backpack i catch backpack ice
catch back patch that gum you like
is coming back and it's your right
you know what is he doing icy
hot back patch icy hot backpack and
i feel about you are saying fake
words i see oh gosh back pat
it it seemed like shaq said i
will give you one take and then
i'm out the door yeah frank sinatra
then it will be lowering my head
out the door yeah you got this
i bet
i love backpage as oh hey my
memory the commercial literally is just him
saying those words like the z yeah
oh shit and we recognize oh check
he just as well in my memory
it's like they demonstrate all the things
like there's an announcer that talks about
it the show and blah blah blah
and they just cut to jag and
goes
that is often
that's all it did and it was
like audio from another time like it's
like not even it's from different him
saying those different words on the chords
just sewed it together yeah of course
yeah he's like hey can i get
some ice for this angle okay we
got that and he's like ah my
patch fell off like we got it
it's gotta put a hot and a
backend there somewhere he's like ooh they
just give people about other players fellows
back oh i got i taught i
see melty d he's doing embarrassed
that's remember that yeah that was a
thing that's that's ha that's huh wonder
what she's doing now she's d j
eng why when she didn't she just
sue someone for something so that's sort
of like nude photos that the person
took oh here we are we've seen
it yeah chef
irvin was not in his head though
but i don't know if it helps
you already you are previous questions
he's four questions behind his head seven
na news is she's like a celebrity
d j now yeah i liked your
song
visiting it was just like a tide
is high riff but it was stars
are blind the tide is hot stars
blinking you look it up chevron google
chef stars are aligned let's hear this
is paris hilton with stars or blog
is this hotel this is dedicated to
young lauren lacus i'm scared
but you've probably she was a hero
to you if i respected her with
all of my being ah
auto-tune the shit out of yeah yeah
a auto tune is really good now
right where it's undetectable kinda yeah so
this is before that is before that
yeah definitely is
oh wait now seven is turning on
the tv apparently we're gonna see this
video and know chevron's getting up to
dance now chevron saying you shirt off
now is ass
he's just showing us the sex tape
come on chevy oh my god this
is the glowing eyes this is terrifying
come on oh
so they showed a way to kind
of give a nod to the tide
is high yeah i like it though
i mean the songwriting over dialogue i
love i'm loving it the only song
i listen to i like the songs
vary but just because it's the tide
is high yeah it is it's not
the exact same know but it's got
all the notes that is high and
oh move it isn't a stretch cut
us off
kind of felt like koska lose my
mind isn't darth vader in the tide
is high video
oh my god what
i swear to god darth vader is
in the titus high video guy he's
an actor
are you talking about well he additionally
he was the master one you're not
talking about the actor whatever his name
is pete pro no i would say
i'm i'm remembering an image of the
titus high video and darth vader to
show the back of darth vader like
hurt like we have to watch the
tide is high video can just google
titus hi darth vader
her i mean you google it chef
google the chef
do do do do what comes up
yep if we see darth vader e
there's a picture of darth vader i
don't know whether that's from i remembering
this is what i'm remembering okay there's
an associate so it's a fake darth
vader because it was around the time
that that star wars empire strikes back
and the thing yeah
amazing how the internet will show you
the answer even though that's not what
you're not yeah like still like the
most darth vader asked thing that they
could get it's like an alien that
looks has sort of a darth vader
ish costume but see look at that
that yeah there's like a shot where
it clearly is supposed to look like
she is singing to darth vader like
you see the bat
yeah okay like riko you see the
back of guy turn it up here
not safe oh that is a darth
vader back of the helmet look look
how shitty this looks hard
videos are fucking sucks
how did they get away with that
everything sucked back then everything sucked out
it was just like oh my god
people are doing things they just showed
like a gutter overflowing and she was
like the tide is high she just
got down and she's because she's mopping
up i mean that's proved shit with
a rag this sucks sucks imaginative side
with the guy
gutters are overflowing i want to see
blondie clean i would much prefer to
see blondie lean
um we need to take a break
when we come back we're gonna have
a feature this is exciting we'll be
right back about you
you guys i mean wherever yeah we're
there we're back all of us i
have a game here for us to
play it's called react and act
party goers who enjoy getting sand trickle
this sounds like us everyone brainstorms a
ton of different events to react to
and know how we're going to
two thousand pounds worth okay we're gonna
modify it everyone will think of one
before
okay good seeing your favorite celebrity in
the street discovering a viper in my
room said biting into a sandwich only
to find a finger this one we'd
said we didn't want to do i
wasn't listening then writes them down and
pops them into a hat we're not
doing any of this we're not just
saying what do we think of something
we're reacting to and then you figure
out what of it okay that's fine
participate
ants will draw one of the events
from the hat and we actually well
everyone else attempts to guess what on
earth they're screaming or fainting about alright
alright ready okay so here i start
okay alright sorry already huh huh is
there a viper under your tie
okay okay okay you go ahead
yeah
celebrity answer yes okay here's mine yes
oh you found a finger in your
sandwich
perfect route o emails
yeah we did okay as well this
sucks because no one can see doing
we're doing
ah okay one another one yes queen
well this one makes no sense queen
oh disease diagnosis one person is the
doctor and everyone else a patient can
the doc figure out which odd diseases
everyone is afflicted with that's all it
says so first we have to be
familiar with arsenal
we have to literally be doctors in
order to diagnose shit causes of death
for murder okay um so that sucks
too so okay um we make up
a game really fast yeah do one
of the do you do remember the
one that you did ah in the
first episode ah
i have to go or whatever oh
ohio okay yeah something like that yeah
okay we're door that well remember if
you know people did like that game
so repeat okay this is the one
was like how the peachtree oh so
you're in the middle of a boring
conversation which you want to oh yeah
make it as casual as possible you
said how high i have to go
higher i have to go okay okay
so let's play again
okay so me and paul will have
a conversation okay
and ultimately they discovered it was a
mole
oh so you didn't have to be
as worried about it as you thought
you had not at all and actually
they didn't even have to remove it
so the um it was all fine
but you could have had it removed
for cosmetic reasons sure but i didn't
yeah you kept them all yeah yeah
yeah that's right no my forehead of
course yeah so it's still oh so
it's it is the one yeah yeah
is that one okay
people yeah but anyways um do you
like chips i like the kind of
chips that i like or the um
know you're here pick wait
i'm enthralled by this i don't want
to go
the diamond was lee
i thought it was wanting you and
i thought it was funny you decided
you had to go thanks always the
third oh okay the conversation like you
can't get any really funny interesting way
i have nothing to add to the
conversation you don't want to be here
in chicago are great fun but i
but i am here and you guys
are acknowledging me yeah okay alright let's
start start starting okay
so i said is there a way
that you can i know you have
to take the cancer part out but
can you make it look like i
still have the mole because it's a
birthmark you know i was born with
it yes i
just on that i catalogued fourteen
i catalogued fourteen new books at the
library today oh that had to be
tagged with the labels and i had
actually not related to what you said
i said on that but it's completely
unrelated i see a connection though actually
but continued with historical tags
so i had to label them scott
and yes it was very hard because
the printer kept breaking go on
and she works at the library so
i couldn't really get the numbers out
and so you so but it was
print ten more books than you had
planned on cataloguing that's why it was
really a big issue yeah yeah yeah
yeah
ah um go on
so i ended up i'd feel it
i ended up getting it done because
i had to um
but when the clock struck five i
had to rush out of work
i heard that um i gotta go
ah say because i got my cat
speaking to work and you could have
just left even speaking to work i
got to go you weren't working you're
going to work i'm going to work
right on that i'm late idea i
have my name is ralph man jack
hello everybody
cause you ain't this
well i guess i didn't quite like
you i love it again i'm ill
but i thought it was between two
people and and that ever use conversation
to something scott it takes two to
make a thing go right it takes
dude wiggling
i thought it was like the people
in the conversation had to do it
no no it's three people talking and
you're like this is boring long forgotten
yeah i thought it was three people
talking you do it and i'll show
you it's ok to whom to paul
the only other person paul what is
what is your ah i notice you're
you're wearing sort of ah i feel
like it's a yeah
ello thai yeah is it ah it
is it like a harsh yellow mustard
some its muster yeah yeah do like
mustard ah you know what's funny as
i don't like muster i'm more of
a ketchup person really like color muster
yeah yeah for ties do you like
having a ketchup tie would be
yeah me so weird yeah oh gosh
oh my cup is so empty so
just gonna let me get something for
yeah yeah this thing around yeah no
wow
i'm a flask here oh but
hey go anyway relish tigers would be
green oh yeah mayonnaise tie would be
just yeah yeah yeah purple thai eggplants
okay so yeah really quick i gotta
go oh i laugh what's your what's
your excuse
this is the let me show you
how it's done
no i'm just not feeling great how
about something like i go by here
let me come to your stomach free
yeah i feel like let me try
okay alright it's ok
and ultimately the humane society suggested that
i continue coming on saturdays are you
in the clear though to be clear
you yeah i'll charge it oh yeah
and but if i come on saturdays
yeah i will um that just worked
better for my schedule yes so you
can yeah because it was some sort
of like work releasing unity serve
community service thing where you because of
all those horses that you can't have
to go play with animals and just
show to show up and be like
oh okay i was just so cute
like it's not really yeah yeah
did he have to go i don't
know he didn't he didn't say he
was very rude he laughed yeah i
just turned your back you have to
actually say i gotta go you gotta
find a way to say i yeah
yeah but get-go turn i feel let's
try that one on one version okay
okay because this is what
i feel like we did last okay
alright so you would me this is
not what we did last time but
let's do okay you and me yeah
yeah and fuck myself and i'm the
one who's gonna excuse myself i we
mean boring okay ah yes i dyed
it blue by the shirt wouldn't hold
the colors so it ultimately ended up
just kind of looking washed
out yeah i bet it did i
gotta go though um i'll see you
later oh boy oh boy yeah she's
very hurtful okay let's do it oh
yeah i'm gonna leave you're gonna leave
okay
but um you know i i feel
like because i work the extra hours
i should get the extra pay but
i was willing to take more time
off at a later tusk so that
i don't i'll trade you the money
for less hours for the same money
you know so essentially
it's like i'm not asking for um
oh no asking for anything special so
totally i'm just saying let me leave
early and then act like i was
there as a little yes that's exactly
you want it so yeah just really
i'm gonna have to go because i
don't know if you root access so
interesting what you're talking about i'm sure
it's here the rest later
you're fucking me is very insulting
see the degree of difficulty is harder
okay now you want and then you're
good on the island guys got
so i don't consider it to be
money-laundering i mean it's you know purely
just like i had this amount of
cash and i was i wanted to
put it into a different you know
place and try something different with it
and so so but you know apparently
the the government feels differently and now
there's a big to do about it
and i
have to go down to an office
right um you know this coming friday
and give them a statement hey paul
can i show you something something really
crazy i have to go
you gene me
folks i think that's all the time
we have some guys we have yes
someone's waiting there's another show twitter oh
wait shows you can get it you
don't even know damn and waving no
chevron is that oh did we coin
that this episode chevron last episode i
think right it's not this one
bins job ten this one we shouldn't
record these back to back because i
think a week season with our bodies
back to back to yeah that's okay
for safety i forget when you guys
look like i like it this way
i like it this way i like
it like that like tie it like
that by we'll see nighttime love you
love you love
yeah
uh